Today, we're going
to see what happens
if we take a vacuum storage bag,
and hook it up to a pump
that has way more power
than a vacuum.
[Music]
Guys, I don't know
if you've ever seen these vacuum
storage bags before.
I've seen commercials for them,
and them in stores
quite a bit.
I've never actually
used one before,
but I had a thought.
I wanted to see just
how they work,
and if we can sort of up
the ante a little bit.
I should point out,
this is not a sponsored video.
I have no allegiance
to this Magic Bag brand.
There's lots of
brands out there.
They all work pretty
much the same way.
These are just the ones
that I bought at Walmart,
because I wanted
to try this out.
Most of the time,
these bags work
with a household vacuum
or a shop vacuum.
You put fluffy
compressible things,
like clothing or
blankets into them.
It's got a one-way valve.
Well, it occurred to me
that we have some pretty
powerful tools around the shop.
Something that can pull
a lot more air than just
a regular shop vacuum.
We've got vacuum pumps.
We've got a couple of them.
This one right here,
this is our Harvest
Right vacuum pump.
This thing is quite
powerful, I think,
and I wanted to see
if there's a difference
between just using
our regular shop vacuum
to pull air out,
and using our vacuum pump.
And then, I've got
a few ideas for things
that we want to try
putting these bags
that aren't exactly what
the manufacturer recommends.
Here's the basic idea.
These storage bags are usually
used with a household vacuum
to make your bedding
and clothing smaller.
Well, we're going
to try attaching it
to our vacuum pump to see just
how much air we
can pull out of them.
To start off though,
we've got these
ingredients over here.
You may recognize these
as the ingredients
used for proto putty.
Proto putty is
a mixture of silicon,
water-based activator,
and some corn starch to make
it easier to manipulate.
If you haven't seen this before,
we've used this several times.
We've got whole videos
on how to make it.
It just becomes
a sculptable rubber
that cures, and then,
it's just solid but slightly
squishy rubber forever,
and I want to try using some
of that to make a seal
for our vacuum pump.
This already pulls pretty well
if I just put it on my hand,
or this valve right here,
but I want to make sure it
really gets a tight seal to suck
out every last bit of air
that we can get.
So let's start mixing
up some proto putty.
[Music]
Now, I've got food coloring,
and this serves two purposes.
One, it adds a little bit
of color to it,
which is always nice.
But very importantly,
this food coloring
is water-based,
and the silicone
is activated by the water.
The water is
a very necessary step.
In fact, you could use plain
water with no food coloring,
and you'd get just sort
of a translucent or clear
or white proto putty.
But we like to use the color
because we can see
how much we're putting in,
and it's easy to control
and it's single drops.
Now, if I just stir this
up and let it sit for a while,
this will cure.
This will turn
into a proto putty.
But it's immensely sticky.
This right now will stick
to pretty much everything.
It's really hard
to work in shape.
So, what we use is cornstarch.
You can use other things too.
If you wanted to use
like talcum powder, baby powder,
which I think is
mostly talcum powder,
you can do that as well.
But we use corn starch
because it's cheap,
and it's, you know, it's edible.
So it's pretty safe
to have around.
Just going to pour a bunch
of that in there.
This will mix in.
It will make it
a little bit more opaque.
But it also make it much
much easier to handle,
and makes it less sticky,
and so, you have
a chance to shape it.
Even with the cornstarch though,
it sometimes is helpful to just
give it a little bit of time.
It takes some time,
a couple of minutes to really
start curing with that water
mixed in, and so,
if it's too sticky, sometimes,
the answer is more cornstarch.
But if you've just been mixing
it for only a minute,
and then the answer might just
be a wait a little bit.
And I should also warn you,
mixing this stuff up puts off
a very strong acetic acid smell.
It's going to
smell like vinegar,
way more concentrated
than an actual bottle of vinegar
from the grocery store.
It's pretty strong.
So, good ventilation
is a good idea.
[Music]
While it's coated in cornstarch,
it's not going to be sticky.
Once all the corn starch
gets mixed in,
it will start sticking
to my gloves again.
There it is.
Just goes everywhere.
You know what?
I already have a vacuum
right next to me.
So that's all right.
This doesn't actually
leak much air.
Once it presses down, this--
So this brass collar
actually moves up and down,
and once it's pressed down,
it doesn't leak anymore.
It forms a tight seal.
But because we're not screwing
this onto a flange or a valve
or anything like that,
it does have a little
more flexibility.
So we're just going
to throw this on just
to make sure we've got
a nice tight seal on it.
Okay, we've got a couple
of decently large blankets
and a very large bag.
I'm not sure
if I'm gonna be able to fit
both of these in here,
but I'm going to try.
And we're going to see
how flat they squish.
Just using the regular vacuum
before we move on
to using the vacuum pump.
[Music]
I am probably
exceeding the recommended
total amount being put
into this bag right now.
[Music]
All right.
Now, let's see if I can
seal this off properly.
This isn't a zipper
that opens one way
and closes the other.
It is just a little tool
to help you close down
the to zip points.
All right, here it goes.
All right.
I think that has stopped moving.
That's pretty dense.
I'm going to be
interested to see
how much more this can pull out,
because that seems like
it's pulled out quite a bit.
It is definitely
flattered and skinnier,
and it may add some unintended
wrinkles into things,
but it's for storage.
Not bad.
We've got our suction cup.
Should just fit nicely on there.
Make a nice tight seal.
Turn this on.
Certainly, suctioning
well to my hand.
Probably just gave myself a
hickey in the middle of my palm.
Oh, that is still
getting a lot flatter.
That is pulling
out a lot more air.
So I'm gonna say, yeah.
We've got a lot
more suction power that than
with our regular vacuum cleaner.
Oh my gosh.
I just want to let
more air back in,
and watch it go.
I'm going to try
and just break the seal here,
open the zipper,
and just have all
that are rush in all at once.
Here it goes.
That's fun to watch.
So, we know
that the vacuum pump pulls a lot
harder than our vacuum cleaner,
and we've seen what it can do
to a pair of blankets.
It shrinks them down,
it's basically a board.
But we're not just going
to do this with blankets.
We've got some other things
we want to try this with.
Let's see.
I think first off,
I have a couple marshmallows.
I like these ones.
You can eat them like an apple.
[Music]
Marshmallows make a really
tight seal once they
smush themselves together.
So it's not really able
to pull more after that.
Although, I don't think
there's much air in there,
except inside the confines
of the marshmallows themselves.
It's kind of just making
a interesting texture there too.
We've seen those
gel like pillows.
I'm just gonna give this
a quick little test.
That's not bad.
It's pretty good.
It's also really nice
for good late-night snack.
You just like, oh man,
I could go for a marshmallow.
Next up, we've got about
two gallons of orbeez here,
and we're gonna see
what happens if we try
and vacuum these.
This will be interesting.
[Music]
That pulled in
water pretty quick,
and then it started
pulling in orbeez.
We managed to pull
in some orbeez sludge
into our hose here.
Don't think they got so far
as to actually get
into the vacuum.
So that didn't last very long,
but we do have one more thing
we're going to try with that.
We're going to use the shop vac.
It's a wet dry shop vac,
so that gets a little bit
of water in it,
it's not going to
cause any problems.
It's not going to pull as hard.
But at least,
it's not going
to get orbeez stuck
inside our nice
expensive vacuum pump.
So let's try this.
Orbeez?
Full of water,
large and non-compressible.
Marshmallows, full of air.
Unfortunately, non-porous.
But we do have one more thing
that we want to try
that's mostly full of air,
and I think is fairly porous.
It should smash
down quite a bit.
We're gonna use one
of our big bags again.
This time we're going to start
with the vacuum cleaner again,
our shop vac,
just because there's
a good chance
that some of this popcorn
could get crumbled up,
or the air flow going
out could pull lots
of little bits into it,
and that's fine
with the shop vac.
Again, we don't want
that to happen
to the vacuum pump,
but I'm hoping that
after it compresses down,
there will be less of that dust,
and we can move on
to using that.
But let's see
how squished it gets was
just our shop vacuum.
This is already
quite entertaining.
There's there's no flexibility
to this at this point.
All-- The air has been pulled
out enough that like,
even though this is just single
popped kernels of popcorn.
Like there's no bending.
They're just pressed
together so tight.
Listen to that.
That's the sound of popcorn.
All right, let's try
and kick this up a notch,
and see what's going to happen.
Hopefully, we don't end
up pulling a lot
of popcorn dust into our pump.
Here it goes.
I can hear all
the popcorn getting crushed.
[Music]
I gotta try something.
This feels very sturdy,
much more sturdy
than popcorn traditionally is.
That's barely...
Like it's not moving,
and it's barely making
any noise, even like...
Wonder if you can use this
to sneak your own popcorn
into a theater.
Maybe I should have used
the medium sized bag.
Guys, popcorn does compress
down a little bit.
All the air gets pulled out,
and it just becomes
really immobile and rigid,
which I thought was pretty cool.
That really had a lot
of strength to it.
I was able to stand
on it, like well.
It didn't even seem
like it was moving or shifting.
Guys, if you have any ideas of
things you'd like to see us try
putting in these vacuum bags,
let us know down
in the comments.
You can actually add a hashtag.
So we're going to
use the #vacuumbag.
If you use that,
we should be able
to search and find it,
and find all of the things
that linked to the video.
So, let us know
if you've got some ideas.
Guys, some of our favorite
projects are about
to become available as kits
in a monthly subscription.
Click the link down
below to be the first
to find out what's coming.
Guys, we've always
got more for you see.
The box up there at the top
is going to take you directly
to our last videos.
You should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
That's probably a good one too.
And if you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel.
That way, you're never gonna
miss a cool video,
especially if you remember
to ring that bell,
so you get the
notification about it.
We'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.